vingt-deux mètres de haut si 1800 places
assises avec cette super tribune la
ryder cup 2018 est déjà inscrite dans
l'histoire de la compétition avant même
d'avoir commencé sa capacité cinq fois
supérieure à celle de la dernière
édition organisée en 2016 aux états unis
et joueurs amateurs du golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines n'en
reviennent pas à les impressionnantes
année elle est belle elle est grande
pour le départ du assez parfait elle est
immense
j'ai entendu dire qu'elle faisait 6000
places
je suis impressionné la tribune éphémère
encore en cours de construction
permettrait d'avoir une vision sur 11
des 18 trous du parcours
les spectateurs pourront notamment voir
le premier coup de la compétition le
vendredi 28 septembre l'ambiance autre
numéro 1 est devenu quelque chose dans
l'héritage de la ryder cup c'est
mythique l'ambiance quand tu les veux
rentrer dans l'arène et ce bruit
assourdissant donc je pense qu'on a
voulu amplifier encore plus parce que
non seulement il ya les 6800 personnes à
6 mais il y aura aussi la même voire dix
mille personnes debout pour avoir sa
place dans cette tribune et spectateurs
devront faire sonner le réveil entre 5
heures et 6 heures du matin objectif
être les premiers à accéder au site
il ya des placements dans la tribune un
peu derrière un peu plus bas à peu près
du départ du 1 qui qu'on pouvait au gré
des
notre billet pour préserver la place
mais sur les 6800 place il ya simplement
1000 places qui ont été préservés
il ya 5800 c'est pour toute personne qui
est sur l'eau si bien billets ils ont
accès ici à la tribune en parallèle de
cette superstructure le golf a vu se
dresser des pavillons et des tribunes
pouvant accueillir des milliers de
spectateurs sur le parcours
l'ensemble sera livré au plus tard le 19
septembre avant le passage des
différentes commissions de sécurité